yankspeaks is sponsored by expressvpn
your data is your business protect it at
expressvpn.com
yang
if both sides keep some problems alive
people keep turning out on that oh yeah
i can get you angry about this issue
forever um but then if we have a
compromise and
immigration could be like you know the
perfect issue about this
people have been looking and agreeing on
many aspects of immigration reform for
years
uh but right now if they don't do
anything it ends up empowering you
in terms of voting energy and
financially
because your base is very very ginned up
about it
and so you almost don't want it to go
away like if you solve the problem
then what are you gonna do to whip
people up exactly and
and so what's interesting is about a
decade ago
surveys showed that democrats and
republicans had roughly
similar views about the value
that they believed immigrants brought to
the country
and now 10 years later because of this
successful weaponization of the issue
the views are wildly divergent which now
leaves this as something no one wants to
solve
and they'll keep raising money on it and
turning out
people on it and there's something wrong
with an industry
that has more money flowing into it the
more they don't solve the problems
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks
the founder of the institute for
political innovation
former ceo of a multi-million dollar
business and now
political reformer and author of a
tremendous book
called the politics industry catherine
gail
welcome catherine i am so happy to be
here andrew thanks for having me
well i'd learned so much from your book
that you co-authored with michael porter
who's one of the
grand fathers i guess that maybe
godfathers he doesn't want to sound old
like the godfathers of management
consulting and business wisdom
and the way you both approached what's
going wrong
with uh our political system
was to me so spot on but i want to start
way way earlier which is
how the heck did you come to this sort
of work uh you know i
i looked at your background where you
worked in business for a long time
uh it seems like and even started and
ran your your own company
yeah it's interesting i really ended up
here precisely because
most of my career really was in business
and ended up having this particular take
on
the on the politics industry because
most of my career was in for-profit
industry
and really how it how it went is
i i mean a long time ago growing up
i was all about politics and then
eventually you know i was in business
and i i got really engaged again because
i cared about the direction of the
country i cared about the policies and
and i now had a daughter since then a
son and you know you're it's sort of
prototypical which is what is the world
we're leaving to our children and how
are things going
and it didn't take
too long after pretty much intense
engagement
to be disappointed with the results out
of washington dc
and so i went through what i call my
five stages of political grief which was
sort of my turn of what how could we fix
this oh we need better candidates oh
that doesn't work
we need better policy oh we have good
policies no one will pass it
oh we need a better culture where people
want to work together
oh they say they want to work together
but they really don't
in the end they vote the same way oh i
know we need independent candidates that
aren't beholden to the duopoly
shoot they can't get elected so those
are the first four stages of grief
and finally it was made clear to me
that you know politics isn't broken
washington isn't broken it's working how
it's designed to work
which is to say that we have a systems
problem
and i read this phenomenal book by
mickey edwards a former republican
congressman
who wrote about the parties versus the
people
and he brought forth to me this system's
argument
and i have never looked back now it's
actually quite embarrassing in the sense
that it took me that long to figure it
out because
everything is a systems challenge really
right in our businesses we're trying to
figure out what are the systems what are
the incentives what's the behavior that
follows those incentives
and when we see a problem we don't hope
for change
we don't get a new leader on top of a
totally
uh dysfunctional business processes and
think that
you know if our company meetings are
more inspirational then
our business processes are sort of not
going to suck anymore you know we think
we should fix that and yet in politics
we've never
looked at it with the same analytical
view so i got the sense from reading
your book
that um you started out on a kind of a
progressive left-leaning
bent uh politically and then michael
kind of came with the
um sort of right leaning and so between
the two of you you felt like look this
is nonpartisan
which i agree with um but i just wanted
to rewind to when you were younger
and it seemed like you were highly
engaged politically
were there particular candidates that
you liked or didn't like
how would you classify yourself at that
time
growing up i was absolutely republican i
grew up in a republican area republican
family i remember picking up the
gerald ford button that had been
discarded
at my elementary school on this side
well you know what's funny is because
you and michael described this thing and
i
wasn't sure which was which oh did he
okay well he is a conservative as well
but point b i grew up as a republican
it was fifth grade and i picked up the
gerald ford button i was so
you know sad that he had lost and and i
continued into high school
at which point i definitely consider
myself a libertarian
and eventually um when i got
back involved as sort of in my
professional adult life
i lived in chicago and i
chose to work with then state senator
you know
barack obama and so i got involved as a
democrat you know there's
only two sides i actually would not
first of all i describe myself now as
politically homeless
i would tell you that even then i was
politically homeless
if you wanted to actually map my policy
views
against what the parties say they're for
which of course we know it's also
different than what they get done but
i'm not
i'm actually um i mean i'm still so
politically homeless but i'm
very fiscally conservative i was deeply
concerned about the debt and the deficit
i was
waiting for the grand bargain in the
obama administration watching every day
like it was the you know biggest drama
going on
and disappointed when we couldn't get
that done so long story short
i'm really a true independent and
michael my co-author from harvard is
what he calls a massachusetts republican
and if you think about that that's you
know mitt romney and charlie baker
these republican governors of blue
states
uh there's a bit of a well not just a
bit there's quite a bit of pragmatism
in massachusetts state politics so
so we come together more from the
business angle
and from the solving problems angle and
from
less of an ideological religion
place and more of a look at these things
that aren't
working we have a lot
going for us in this country we must
be able to solve these we can't look at
two decades and say oh yeah we still did
nothing about that
i come from a similar background where i
ran a private company it doesn't sound
like it was as big as
uh gale foods um but
there's like a similar orientation where
you're there you're leading a team of
people
you have problems and you're like all
right like how do we try to move the
organization forward how do we
solve that problem how do we grow
revenue how do we get more customers how
do we
reduce expenses and there's this entire
constant uh atmosphere of objectivity
that suffuses the place
because if you're a small private
company you're not allowed to
lie to yourself really if
you lie to yourself then things are
gonna go poorly for your business
uh pretty quickly um and it sounds like
that was like a similar set of
experiences you had because you ran a
private company and i imagine
uh like there's a similar culture of um
of data and results is that right
absolutely you know when i came into my
company it really was a turnaround
situation
so we were uh not
even on a flat trajectory you know we
were headed the wrong direction so there
was a lot
of urgency and and the
internal dynamics and the management
decisions that you just speak of ring
true to me but here's the
other point that i'll bring up are
the pressure on us you as ceo of your
of your test prep company me as ceo of
gale foods
is given in large part by the
marketplace
which is to say oh if my customers
don't like these products or they don't
like the price or the quality or
whatever that's not working
they're not gonna buy from me because
they have other choices
and if eventually
you know they're so dissatisfied but
they don't have enough other choices a
new competitor is going to come in this
market
to say we can make you know the products
catherine makes i i made uh
sort of high-tech dairy products so
dairy products that were self-stable
nachos and diet drinks and
uh yogurt smoothies and things and but
so someone else can come in the market
and offer that product better and then
we're done you know i mean we can come
back but point being revenues go down
we're accountable to our customers and
what ended up happening when i was sort
of wrestling with the systems problem is
i was doing my company strategy and i
was saying
hey how come i have to
serve my customers in order to keep and
grow my business that's the connection
and in politics our elected officials
let's say in congress
there is not a connection between
serving the public interest doing what
the citizens
need their government to do and getting
re-elected
those things are not connected and the
second thing that's not connected is
how come 90 of citizens are sort of
regularly surveyed as being dissatisfied
with congress
and yet and dissatisfied with both
parties you know
over 50 think we need a new third party
but we never get any new competition how
come
yeah it's like a marketplace where
market dynamics don't apply
like like the kind of business physics
that you expect or the market
dynamics uh just don't apply because
of a number of reasons that you lay out
with with uh michael in your book
how did you connect with michael on this
book which i thought was a very
impressive work and really important
uh like how did how did the two of you
decide you know what there needs to be a
book
on the politics industry and i'm gonna
write half of it you're gonna write half
of it uh you know uh
like how did that come about well
actually i developed politics industry
theory
beginning in 2013 when i was still
full-time running my company and it came
out of my company strategy project when
i was using michael porter's five forces
to do this strategy project for this
high-tech dairy foods company
and that was when all these key
epiphanies came so i already had
uh sort of the five forces completed
and understood the dysfunction and the
election system and the legislative
machinery and everything
but i almost it was almost like i just
found it interesting for myself
you know i wasn't intending to write on
it or do anything was just like
oh my gosh that's so fascinating then
after i sold my company because i knew
some innovations and changes we need in
the system i wanted to work on those
i started working on them and couldn't
really get business people engaged they
were
mia and it goes back to what we said at
the beginning it's almost like these
business people felt that
you know congress and politics was
totally irrational
and they just couldn't get their mind
around how they could ever make a
difference over there because it was
inconceivable to them
how they keep doing what they're doing
and i decided
that i needed to write a business case
i needed to write a thesis for
investment not of money although that
too
but of time and engagement that would
appeal to
all the you know business people in the
country to understand no no
politics is every bit as rational and
the actors and they're rational the same
way they are in our business
and if we look at systems instead of the
fight the drama the
the front end we can figure out how to
fix it and
so i wanted to write it and use the five
forces and everything and i
actually asked michael to join me as my
co-author really
just as a favor so that did you did you
know michael i had
that yeah i knew him yes actually he
worked with me on my company strategy
so i done the five forces with the
michael porter you know but we
hadn't worked on politics he wasn't
involved in politics that was not his
thing so michael porter wrote a seminal
business book
um called five forces that ended up
becoming this management consulting
framework
for business problems and so what he
suggested was look when you
arrive at a a business
set of decisions then you should examine
the five forces that go into
that situation and so those five forces
i'm gonna miss at least one of them so
i'm gonna supply a couple and then you
can fill out
the other three so one's competitors
two is suppliers uh three is substitutes
four is and then go ahead and give us
four and five the ones you missed are
the barriers to entry
and the channels and the five forces
says how is the power
and the value in this industry divided
up
and on what basis is it divided up and
that's what we end up seeing
using these five forces is that the
customers in the politics industry
don't have much of the power or the
value
if you're listening to this show you
probably love podcasts i want to
recommend one that
we've been listening to and dabbling
into and um
that has some fascinating stuff that's
made for the yang gang in many ways
remain for our listeners in many ways so
the jordan harbinger show is what we're
talking about and i just listened to one
with a guy named david shimmer who comes
and talks about
how our elections have been kind of
covertly interfered with for the past
100 years so like
election interference is not new it is
something that's been happening for a
while sometimes it's foreign sometimes
it's harmless
sometimes it doesn't affect the election
at all sometimes it's massive it was
really fascinating to listen to this guy
uh just jordan just has this ability to
talk to some of those brilliant minds
out there and make it simple for us to
simple and actionable for us to take
things away so
search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b
as in boy i n as in nancy g-e-r
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcast
so that's jordan harbinger show you can
google it you can find it on podcast
and it's um it's worth your time it's
worth your energy it's worth your
intellectual curiosity frankly so a ton
interesting people check it out jordan
harbin your show
he's the harbinger of knowledge
so you back in 2013 you started uh
musing to yourself you know what like
the
the business uh
business case analysis that we use
actually would apply to politics
so you'd look up and say okay um who
what are the channels
uh what are the barriers to entry the
barriers to entry are incredibly high
politics i guess that there is that i
i think you can be an exhibit for us
although candidly
you really got incredibly far given the
barriers to entry but we can
go into that more too well well even
then and we can go into this catherine
but um
even then like there were people that
sometimes asked me it's like hey why
would you run
as a democrat as opposed to an
independent or some other things
um and often i would give them a very
practical answer and say look if you run
as an independent uh
you have zero chance so when you talk
about the barriers to entry it's like i
had
barriers to face running within the
party system
um and those barriers were significant
but
as you suggest you know we managed to
overcome a significant number of them
um but i looked at the barriers for
let's say an independent run as did
someone like mark cuban who
you know i spoke to on the podcast and
whatnot and those barriers
are uh essentially insurmountable if you
were to
to put it in those terms even for
someone like mark who was looking at
potentially you know
like um spending millions of dollars
let's note
even for someone like donald trump who
originally considered running
with the third party reform party yeah
and that's one reason why like my
conversation with justin amash
you know i mean which i thought was uh
fascinating on several levels but
uh there there are there's a very very
steep drop off after democrat republican
in american political life you know like
depending upon your context you would
suggest
um you know the biggest uh third parties
so to speak would be the green party or
socialist party or uh libertarians
um and then there's this classification
of independent
that is actually very significant more
people self-identify now as independent
as either democrat or republican
the reality is that most of those
independents vote pretty consistently
for other democrat or republican but
they're
they are um you know officially
independent but there is no independent
party
uh and uh you said earlier that over
half of americans now kind of wish there
was a third party
um but this is not an environment where
uh that actually ends up manifesting
itself in a viable third party because
uh the two-party system is essentially
um entrenched and
uh it makes it very very difficult for a
third party to arise
um so so these are some of the things
that um you know that you point out in
your book so i just want to say that you
know
thank you for saying that i overcame
some barriers but i looked at other
barriers and was like
you know i'm not dumb enough to think
that
that those barriers are manageable
yeah and it's it's looking at these
barriers is important because
uh you know again in a private industry
in many cases you would love for it to
be very difficult
for new competitors to you know get
started against you because you can
sort of have higher prices um if you
have a protected
industry and
but you still usually have to serve your
customers but in
uh in politics you can both not do what
needs doing
and make a lot of money in a sense in
the industry
yeah your analysis was very trenchant uh
on many of these points and
you you said earlier that there is a lot
of discontent
with uh congress writ large so
right now congressional approval ratings
around the country are 21
that is you know 21 of us think congress
is doing a great job
uh and the re-election rates for
members of congress are consistently 90
plus i looked over the last several
decades
and came up with 94 um so so that's
a very very significant gulf
between 21 and 94
uh and and that bears out a lot of what
you're describing where
uh you can be unhappy with congress
we're at large
but and so you would think in a
particular system well that would mean
that they would all lose office
you know two years two years later but
it turns out that essentially the exact
opposite is true
where the vast majority of incumbents
will win re-election if they decide to
do
to run again uh and so then you ask well
why is that and that's one of the things
you guys go into
in the book is you try and break down
the mechanics
as to why it is that incumbents will win
94
of the time yeah you know
here's the thing that's interesting a
i came to politics industry theory you
know in figuring out this competition
lens and everything because i was in
business but the other thing that i
brought to now my full-time work in
business because i sold my i mean my
full-time work in this
political innovation because i sold my
company the other thing i brought was
all i care about is action and results
so before i even answer this question i
want to step back for a moment
our book my work my institute for
political innovation
everything is about driving towards
the actions that people in congress
take or don't take the results that they
deliver for the country
or not so whenever
we recommend a change we have to be
recommending it only based on not
because it feels more democratic or it
feels more fair
or it feels you know sort of i don't
know just nicer or anything like that
we want to recommend something because
we think it's likely to
substantively influence the likelihood
that congress solves problems for the
american people
and the second thing is we don't want to
talk about
anything that just theoretically would
make congress solve problems for the
american people
but that we can't do as in like let's
talk about
a new a new constitution that would help
congress solve problems well we can't do
that so let's
not waste our time so we don't as a
business person here i just
i just want the results i'm not about
ideology
um and i and i
want when we talk to people
if they buy in i want there to be a path
to achieving the new you know the new
changes
you're a business person you would never
recommend some pie in the sky
solution you're looking around saying
okay and i love the diagnosis too you
look up and say well
what are the incentives of these actors
and you realize and this is
very similar to what justin amash was
saying it's like the incentive for
a sitting member of congress uh is not
necessarily to
stand up for some compromised solution
that might move the
the ball for folks in their district
their incentives are very much around
going along with party leadership uh
avoiding avoiding a primary challenge
um because over 80 percent of districts
are drawn in a way that you have a safe
seat so it's either going to be
very blue or very red and so what you
need to worry about
is making yourself a target for primary
voters from within your party
and less than 20 of folks in the
district will actually show up
for your primary so you have to cater to
the folks who are at the ideological
edge
of your constituents and then you're
trying to
um keep the edge within the edge happy
to avoid a significant primary challenge
and that's where all of your incentives
lie
um your incentives are not trying to
appeal to 51 percent of the people in
your district which you would think
would be um the incentive because it
turns out your district
is has been drawn in a way that uh the d
or the r is going to win
uh you know like 90 times out of 100 or
95 times out of 100.
uh and so you're doing what the system
uh
is pushing you to do it's just that it's
not what we all
imagine your incentives are uh you know
we think
like you're supposed to quote unquote
serve the people when really
your incentives are to avoid primary
challenge
by the most ideologically extreme 10 of
the folks in your district is that a
fair summary yeah it's so a way of
looking at it
is to say there's no connection between
doing what needs doing
for the people for the public interest
and getting reelected but there
is a connection between doing what
leadership wants you to do
doing what the ideological
you know more ideologically extreme
part of your party that shows up in
primaries wants you to do
and doing what donors and special
interests want you to do
so essentially the key for us is
how can we change that design
so we break this connection
and we make the connection with the
public interest
connect public interest and re-election
because
i want to note one thing so many of your
well you may have super sophisticated
listeners but i'll say let's say writ
large
so many people do have a sense about the
primary
but mostly what people think is oh it
makes people say
crazy things like oh they say this
to get elected but the real thing we
need to understand
is what they say is not really the
problem it's again what they're incented
to do which you were getting at and so
what happens is when they get there both
sides
they let's put a real situation in front
of us
okay we have a compromise bill
with these complex trade-offs on
immigration
or health care or debt reduction
and we need to you know consider it
here's kind of a bill that behind closed
doors we all agree
represents a way to move the country
forward and some reasonable trade-offs
we don't all get what we want
here it is and now this republican and
this democrat thinks well
how do i vote on that and no matter what
they said behind closed doors
the questions you think they would ask
is is this the right idea is this going
to move the country forward is this what
the majority of the people in my
district want but the only question they
ask
is well or the first question is
will i make it back through my party
primary if i vote for this
and on almost all the big issues the
answer to that
question is always no for both sides
because they've pushed themselves so far
apart and they've politically weaponized
every issue so they can turn out their
base
that now they're a prisoner to those
weapons themselves
and they can't say yes to anything
rational you can't compromise because
you've made it seem like
it's uh life or death existential
struggle and there's like uh you know
right or wrong on it and so
all of a sudden you'd be like yeah it
turns out the other side was had some
merits on this
you know there there were folks that
will um
uh be very very upset with you or even
just giving a win to the other party
before the midterms or the next election
you don't want anybody to win other than
your party so what we're seeing now
is that both parties hold out for
a trifecta where they control both
chambers and the presidency and then
push through their own agenda which then
sort of results in this tug of war both
in the courts and then maybe when
control switches of trying to repeal
rather
or replace rather than improve and then
the other party will wait them out
and try to move forward so because they
don't want the other party to have any
wins to go back to the district with
because again if you keep i
this is extraordinary if both sides keep
some problems alive
people keep turning out on that oh yeah
i can get you angry about this issue
forever um but then if we have a
compromise and
immigration could be like you know the
perfect issue about this
people have been looking and agreeing on
many aspects of immigration reform for
years
uh but right now if they don't do
anything then they can animate their
base around
uh like this issue and say
and then at this point now unfortunately
we've descended into some very
irrational
conversations around um immigration but
it ends up empowering you in terms of
voting energy and financially because
your base is
very very ginned up about it uh and so
you almost don't want it to go away like
if you solve the problem
then what are you gonna do to whip
people up
and yeah what are you gonna do to get
the campaign contributions what are you
going to do to get the turnout what are
you going to do
to run the ads you know exactly and and
so what's interesting is
about a decade ago surveys showed
that democrats and republicans had
roughly similar views
about the value that they believed
immigrants brought to
the country and now 10 years later
because of this successful weaponization
of the issue
the views are wildly divergent which now
leaves this as something no one wants to
solve
and they'll keep raising money on it and
turning out people on it
and there's something wrong with an
industry
that has more money flowing into it the
more they don't
solve the problems yeah that's the
fundamental incentive problem it's like
look
um we're we'll be very successful uh as
long
as people are excited or upset
or donating money and solving the
public's problems actually does not tie
into our success electorally our success
financially
and that's how you wind up with a very
very dark
world where uh where at this point
you're better served by not actually
solving
some of the country's biggest problems
and by making them existential which is
the word
you just used making everything
existential
whereas you know in
there's this this duopolistic thinking
and we have a duopoly only two
competitors but then all the issues it's
either this
or it's this and i often say that you
know
that's a particular challenge and here
i'll hearken to some of the issues you
brought up
these pace of change right now
means that we need an innovative
government that we need to generate
new ideas new solutions experiment with
with new um policy directions
in order to see how we can deal
with this fourth industrial revolution
that we're going through
and yet our our politics you know
does not allow us to do that
we would rather stick with you know
just our same old ideas
because there's no benefit to bringing
up the new
and so i am here's another way of saying
um i want to say to the listeners right
now
not only am i politically homeless for
example and michael you know just
independent problem solving thinking
person etc even
i have no problem with
writ large sort of over time the
republicans or
the democrats i don't have any problem
with political parties
that they could and need to exist and i
don't even have any problem with
two parties here's the problem the
current two are guaranteed to continue
to be the only two
kind of forever regardless of what they
do
or don't get done on our behalf so
i say you know to republicans and
democrats and everybody
when we get healthy competition it's not
about
annihilating people's passions or their
ideologies or annihilating groups of
people working together on
issues it's about making sure that
the parties that end up to be the main
parties are the ones that are delivering
on behalf of uh you know the majority of
the country
um and and moving it forward and so it's
just altering the competition it doesn't
mean
that uh all the existing people are evil
it means that the system is
really really bad the system makes it
harder for folks to go in there and
be principled and do the right thing i
mean that's what the conversation with
justin amash
uh clearly leads you to believe and
i agree with you that uh in in the best
possible world we'd be able to look up
and say hey
like what were the results of that uh
set of policies or that initiative
uh and then be able to hold political
parties
uh or sets of leaders um either we could
celebrate them and say that was a
fantastic move
or or uh or it wasn't and then you have
some kind of objective standard to
measure them on
the you know right right now because of
the nature of our politics it it it's
become
increasingly um non-data driven
like it's becoming increasingly argument
driven and it's like just appealing to
different for people sensibilities you
have different media companies and now
social media
um just uh profiting from our
polarization
in various ways and that also reinforces
the the two-party dynamic
um so you recommend a number of big
changes
that you think would help things uh
including rank choice voting which i'm a
huge fan of and to me
uh like ideally both parties um end up
becoming what i would call pro-democracy
uh in in the way that you're describing
it where you have
you just have some very flawed
incentives and if you look up and say
i mean here's the most basic flawed
incentive now if i'm a member of
congress
right now i'm spending 30 to 70 of my
time raising money uh because
that helps make sure i get reelected
that helps uh
that helps me climb the party ladder
that helps me eventually get committee
positions and whatnot
and if you were to line up americans and
be like hey
do you like the fact that your
representative is spending half their
time raising money be like no i'd rather
they spend
a hundred percent of their time figuring
out policies or meeting their
constituents needs or the rest of it
uh i mean that's like a pretty basic one
where like most people could look up
would look up no
one would say like yeah i love the idea
of them just dialing for dollars all the
time
uh so imagine how much more effective
legislators they would be if they did
not have to do that
you know uh and so so that's like a huge
step that i think most americans would
be thrilled about
um so what are the
the big moves that you you and michael
arrived at um and that you recommend and
i obviously read the book so i have a
sense of them
but but it might not be exhaustive
because you do other work uh you know
beyond the book and you know you might
have even discovered some new things
since the book was written
that's interesting uh i i think there
there's always more to discover
that's all started there's there are
many ideas
and there are many things that could be
improved but again let's go back to
business for a moment
and by the way i'm not saying government
should be run like a business i'm saying
that understanding how to get the best
performance out of
people in organizations deals with
incentives so but point being
uh going back that's very very smart i
agree with you on both fronts
yeah okay so um there's a
saying well quote also actually from my
co-author michael porter strategy is
about choosing what
not to do so
we in my first publication uh that i did
actually with michael also in 2017 i
thought that i had narrowed down the
recommendations
but in retrospect i look at it and say
well that was kind of a laundry list
so for this book we really got to the
difficult choices
which we make in business all the time
we could serve this market bring out
these 10 products but no we're only
going to bring out two products because
those are the
only ones we can support and these are
the best ones so on
the innovations
innovations into two areas first the
things we need to change
in how we vote in the elections
machinery
and i call it machinery because um
it reliably spits out
behavior just as reliably as any piece
of equipment in my manufacturing firm
did
so the the rules of elections
spit out these incentives and therefore
this behavior
and then there's a second kind of
machinery which justin amash and you
were talking about a lot
which is the legislative machinery so
the rules and process of how
you get legislation passed or not
spits out certain kinds of behavior and
certain kinds of legislation mostly no
legislation or party legislation or bad
legislation anyway
so we need to fix both
but the first thing is how we vote
and when strategy is choosing what not
to do
i've arrived absolutely at one primary
recommendation
we should implement final five voting
that is a package of two
changes to how we vote the first
change is let's get rid of party
controlled
primaries we've talked about it they
push
everybody too far apart so they simply
cannot keep their jobs if they work
together that's like saying to everybody
here
do your job really well you'll lose your
job
so that's crazy we have to change it and
what
one thing i love talking to all your
listeners um
and viewers but talking to you i say
can we come together knowing that
nonpartisan open primaries are
every bit as important as rank choice
voting you know what yang speaks we're
serious about
our data is our property we should have
control over it we should know what
happens to it now
while we're waiting for congress to get
its act together what can we do to
actually protect our data
expressvpn is the software that i and
thousands
of listeners use every day to protect
our data online
i've been talking about expressvpn on my
show for so long now that
most of you already signed up i'm
kidding
if you have it why should you uh
it's like a button where it'll beam you
to another
part of the internet and then whatever
you do no one knows what you did
you know what i mean it's like uh and
that's why
corporations use it so they can have
their employees do things and not have
it be monitored by the
internet service provider or anyone else
or the big tech companies
or the data brokers so if that sounds
appealing to you
you should definitely check out
expressvpn because they are
top rated by cnet wired and a lot of
other folks who just
look at virtual private networks all day
and say which one of you
should i recommend and they settled on
expressvpn
so my question is why haven't you gotten
expressvpn yet
our link expressvpn.com
will give you an extra three months of
expressvpn for free
protect your data today with a vpn i
trust to keep my data safe go to
expressvpn.com to get started
one of the things about these vpns out
there that is not expressvpn like some
of the cheap knockoffs is that they
actually sell your data
so that's how they make their money and
one of the reasons we actually looked
into
the vpn options why we love expressvpn
they don't do that so they're actually
aligned with
what we stand for at humanity forward
and and ng's presidential run so
check this out guys protect yourself vpn
that
we use and trust so use our link
expressvpn.com
today get an extra three months free on
a one year package
let's talk a little bit about what are
the negative effects of party controlled
primaries
uh so we've touched on it a little bit
and i've seen it um
so uh number one is you're gonna have an
incumbent from one of the two parties
um and so if you have a safe seat then
and i've been supporting candidates down
balance so i've seen some of this
um so you can have the person get
primaried from within their party
um and then if they get to the general
then
it's a foreground conclusion like you
know you don't even need to pay
attention to the general really in a lot
of these districts in like 80
of the districts so you wind up with
only one real
challenge to the incumbent and that is
within their party primary
because you have a party controlled
primary system
um so by the general election it's
already
determined who's going to win there's a
quote by william tweed
that said um yeah
that that said i don't care who does the
electing as long as i get to do the
nominating
so um so uh so
the so the problem with the party
controlled primary system
is that uh it restricts voter choice
uh is is that a fair way to characterize
it again i
i absolutely want more voter choice but
let's
fast forward i want more freedom for
legislators to do what needs doing
yeah you want a good result yeah again
the real problem
is not what they're saying in the
primary or who even makes it through the
primary
it's what they do once they're there we
if we
if we got rid of party controlled
primaries
some of the talented passionate elected
officials will still
win but they will now have the freedom
to do
what needs doing okay so so that's one
of the problems with the party primaries
but
here's the another thing that i think
you might you in particular might find
really interesting
i don't know if you call this part in my
book because it's short i'm working on a
longer
a longer article it's called the dual
currencies of politics
oh yeah i found this fascinating when
you talk about
votes and money um and that money is
actually a better currency because if
you get
extra you get to keep it and more of
it's always better
whereas voting if you get extra votes
then you don't get to roll them over to
the next election
there's a lot of nuance to this so uh
again remember we're looking at now
politics as an
industry and so we're trying to find out
what's going on in this industry
and here's a lot of times i'm talking
about how it's similar to the for-profit
industry but now i want to talk about
how it's different
politics is the only industry i've come
across that really has
two currencies so think of it this way
some
customers in politics pay with votes
voters some customers a much smaller
number
pay with money donors and special
interests who are also donors
and in large part
so we think a lot of times we have a
money in politics problem
and i want to say here we don't
what we have is a relative
value problem like we have an exchange
rate
problem like you know the dollar being
worth way more than
you know whatever the the euro is worth
or something point being
in politics right now the currency of
money
is worth unbelievably much more than the
currency of votes and i'll give you a
couple examples so as you said
first of all there's a limited utility
because
you only need one vote more than the
other person to win
the other and you can't carry them over
whereas money has no
upside limit on its utility but a couple
other things
the only time votes really have any
value
is in the party primary
but only in half of the primaries right
because
if if the district is gerrymandered or
even naturally occurring
a red district the only votes that have
any value
are the voters that turn out to vote in
the red
republican primary so it's actually if
if voter turnout in a primary is 20 but
you know 10
of the people are turning out here their
votes have
power and have value and then when you
get to the general election
each vote is sort of worth zero
because it's already decided determined
yeah
and you don't you also don't care if you
turn off lots of people with the
currency of votes
because again even if even if you made
everybody so angry
that only 10 people came out for the
election and there were 10 votes
as long as you got six and the other
person got four
it's no problem for you whereas you want
to keep turning out more and more people
sort of to be involved in money
but you're fine if you depress all the
people who are so disgusted with
with you know uh politics that they stay
home so one of the chain
so whenever we're looking at the
innovations i'm talking about i'm
looking at the behavior it's going to
incent but i'm also
always looking back at how does it
change the relative value of votes to
money
and i'm going to tell you a secret about
this money and politics problem
you know why there's so much money it's
just because
it's a really good investment the roi
is really good there are why i'm
lobbying i saw in a study it was
it says something like 17 to one i mean
like where did you
get where the heck can you get a 1700
return on just about anything you do in
business i mean
that's like like if you're a rational
business person you're investing
there you go rational rational behavior
so here's the thing what if we were able
to
artificially decrease by a factor of 10
the amount of money in politics you know
so all the lobbyists are spending
uh you know one ten percent of what they
used to spend
but we leave all the existing rules and
incentives for how people get elected
and the elections machinery and
legislative machinery intact
you know what we're going to do we're
going to essentially make it 10
times cheaper for the self-interested
money
to get the same result
so here's the key make votes
more powerful than money
make that currency the one that matters
and then it won't make all money go out
but the point is if the votes are more
powerful you can't buy with money what
votes don't want
yes that's the dream therefore
therefore then the money that goes in
you know will
will lessen if it's not at all connected
with what's good for the country because
you won't be able to get the roi
on it you won't get the return yeah
people making decisions
why play i can't get what i want
exactly and and that's and that's fair
and
and rational and so i am always telling
people stop going after the money in
politics
and go and making it less powerful and
go after
making voters more powerful and go after
making
general election voters more powerful
having an open primary where everybody's
on the same ballot and then we'd have
five people advance to the general
election
and then you rank choice voting the
general which you know we can come back
to the package
that means that the election is never
decided in the primary
it's always decided in the general and
all of a sudden every voter matters
because you're using rank choice voting
even if the district is deeply red or
deeply blue
that's so much less of a problem with
this system
we sort of leapfrog over the need for
gerrymandering reform
certainly not fair gerrymandering
everything but it's not the gating
factor
let's do final five voting open top
five primaries plus ranked choice voting
in the general elections and in the
general elections alone
and you're going to you're going to rank
these five candidates
and then we'll elect someone with the
majority of you know the broadest appeal
to the most number of voters but
the main reason and that's what a lot of
people that like rcv
talk about is how it's more fair and
democratic and it is those things and
i'm for those things
but for the purpose of caring about
results
that make a difference in real people's
lives the main
and like the the biggest hugest benefit
of ranked choice voting
is that it's it eliminates the barrier
the biggest
barrier in the politics industry to the
new competition
which is the spoiler argument
oh yeah don't vote for that person you
know you're gonna waste your vote et
cetera like you get rid of it
so ranked choice voting gets rid of the
spoiler effect it gets it diminishes the
incentives to campaign negatively
because if you trash someone then
you both look bad and then the person at
third place ends up
uh coming up um it makes it so that
the ultimate winner has at least some
kind of level of
support among uh more than 50 percent of
the
folks which right now if you end up with
you know split votes like you could have
some
person that no one really well not no
one but less than 50 of people like
um ends up winning clearly winner like
happened with the governor in maine
or to some extent with donald trump
during the primary process because there
were there were places he won
with less than 50 percent um during the
nominating process
uh so this is both political parties a
lot of times the
presidential primary you know favors
these plurality
winners and you don't get sort of the
person who's everybody's second choice
but nobody's first
choice yeah so this was an appealing
vision to me the top five
uh and plus ranked choice voting in part
because i was trying to imagine if you
were
an independent-minded person who was
considering running for office
and you got some people behind you and
let's say there's an incumbent
let's call you know it could be either
democratic republican it doesn't matter
for this example
but you think to yourself okay if i get
enough people behind me all i have to do
to make it to the general is be in the
top five
uh and that seems kind of achievable
like i just need to go out and get
enough votes to be in the top five and
then if he goes
if i do get in the top five then we all
contend in a ranked choice voting format
and then if i get a lot of people behind
me not even as their first race
necessarily but like
i become everyone's second choice
because um you know i'm
common sense and suggesting things that
people like and you know like
it seems like i'm going to try to
deliver along with what most of us
want uh so that that's like a very
appealing vision
uh and so i i'm i've always been a fan
of right choice voting and i think
you and michael helped open my mind to
the fact that
the primary system is a huge component
of who can successfully run for office
and then
what their incentives are after they get
there to your point and now we know that
the primary system is a huge reason why
votes have so much less power than money
yeah that too uh because like you said
it's very constrained because
if you're not registered in that party
and one of like the folks who shows up
to that primary then
you're just showing up to the ballot
being like well i don't even really have
and
this is one thing you really do have to
reflect on for a moment is that for the
average person in that district
they don't really have a meaningful
choice uh because
if they weren't able to participate in
the
nominating party's primary then they're
just showing up to the ballot box and
being like okay i can vote for one of
these two people but one of them is
almost guaranteed to win
uh and it's one reason why people uh
write off politics because they're like
my vote doesn't matter like
in like like this is a waste of my time
you know when people have that
perspective
um i look at them and i think like this
person may be rational you know it's
like there's some people being like no
you're a jerk for thinking that it's
like well maybe they're on to something
you know it's like
if you had a system where it was truly
irrational uh then
you could hold people to a higher
standard because you'd be like your vote
really does matter because you can
actually make a difference that you know
and right now i tell people hey look if
you only have time to vote once
just vote on primary day like if you
somehow can't do twice just vote on
primary day
and and and i also you know people are
often saying we need to have universal
voting we need to have mandatory voting
we need to
increase turnout and i say why are we
artificially trying to increase turnout
you know the best way to increase
turnout
make turning out matter make the vote
matter
just like i'm saying the best way to
reduce money in politics is give it less
return on investment
the best way to increase turnout is to
give it more return on investment
and so that's why we we have to stop
going at fixing symptoms
and we have to go with the roost cause
which is misaligned incentives and i
want to
i want to say a couple of things again
based on what i really think you
were your race in the presidential
demonstrates although i'll say also
very i'm i want to tell people
a you have to care about primaries but
the second thing i want to tell people
is let's focus on
congress because a mythical
president no matter how extraordinary
will not change the results out of
washington d.c
all these congress people senators and
house members who have to keep getting
reelected over and over
that's the key linchpin to begin turning
the ship
but here's what we need remember i said
before we need innovation right all
these changes
competition healthy competition
is not about changing who wins it's
about changing what the winners are
incented to do and there's another piece
to that
in healthy competition losers
can also influence the results the same
way in industry so what happens in
technology right
maybe an entrepreneur comes up with a
really great technological improvement
now maybe they grow that into a company
and they
sort of get existing companies out of
the marketplace like you know
we don't have kodak or xerox really so
much anymore right
or they get the idea and it gets bought
by one of the bigger companies but again
the consumer gets the benefit of that
technology
or they have that idea and one of the
other
providers or all of them figure out a
similar way to deliver the same benefit
to the consumer so the consumer benefits
even if the person who came up with the
original idea doesn't end up
you know with sort of the winning
company um
and that's what happens in good
competition so if we go back
to for example 1992 ross perot so i'm
assuming lots of your listeners are too
young to remember this i am not
young ross pero ran in 1992
um against bill clinton and george bush
and he
only got 19 of the vote and zero
electoral votes in november
and he was an independent but he ran on
debt and deficit reduction
this is me making his charts he had all
these tv commercials showing how our
debt was rising rising rising rising
and um he lost
but the american people won because
perot's competition forced
both sides republicans and democrats who
previously
didn't care it was not part of their
platform that they were going to do
something about the debt and deficit
to care about it and it put the
electoral pressure on them to work
together to solve the issue
which means the clinton in this
administration was the last time
we had budget surpluses and when pearl
died last year paul begala who's who
was one of clinton's top advisors um
wrote an op-ed i wrote one too but his
was you know sort of more famous than
mine and he said because he had a better
quote
an inside you know view he said i
am not sure we ever would have
balanced the budget without the pressure
perrault and his voters brought to the
issue
so one of the reasons we need
competition is because we need to get
new innovative policy ideas so this is
what you were bringing to the democratic
primary
strategy about choosing what not to do
you had a lot of focus on the freedom
dividend the universal basic income
and brought that idea to a lot of people
who had never heard of it before
now we don't know where that will
eventually go and i'm not taking a
position on it at this moment
but what i am saying is you injected
yeah that was part of the value i said
look i'm either going to win or the
winners are going to sound
a lot like me that was the goal
uh what i predict is when you have five
people competing in every race
some people will run and they will know
they're unlikely to win
but they may want to bring forward a
constituency
or a problem or
a or a solution and really campaign on
that
and if it gets a lot of voter support it
will influence
the winners and what they do it doesn't
mean that now these winners are captive
to someone who got
you know 12 of the vote it means if
there's validity
and if that validity grows over time by
more and more candidates running around
the country on those same things
if you had a ranked choice voting system
and there were 12 of the folks in your
district that were really into something
you'd pay attention to it because you're
like well like if i pay attention to it
that's going to make me their
second choice so let's do it i mean like
that and that
like that's like better incentives it's
like a real pull
not a behind-the-scenes poll about who
likes you know universal vacant basic
income or who likes
um you know the simpson bulls debt
deficit
uh you know reduction plan you see who's
voting for that
um and and what you'd see is various
ideas would come in
and then if they never really got
traction sort of those candidates and
those things would sort of fade out
and then come back later or never come
back and we'll have other new ideas and
yes we'll have some fringes because
here's the really important thing
i'm not proposing a squishy middle
i think we need more moderates to be
able to work together you just me
you just need more dynamism and
innovation you need more inclusion and
voices
because right now like you know the
marginal
folks just show up and be like well i
can't do anything in this system
so you wind up with very little
innovation if we get
basically a range of ideas and
candidates
and we have innovation and we have
fringes because new ideas often come
originally from what were at the time
fringes both in business
in politics in america when our idea of
having
a representative democracy was the first
right we were fringe we weren't normal
okay so
you have that combined now
with a system where when you're
legislating
you're incented to still work with
people who had a different
idea to find a solution so we get the
benefit of both things
all the innovation and and uh new ideas
and debate as along with incentives to
work
together to make the trade-offs that's
like
i love the idea i love the idea of
elevating the value of votes like if you
look at the exchange rate i think that's
very
powerful and profound so the open top
five primaries plus ranked choice
general elections
we put that together in a package and we
call it
final five voting i think it's helpful
the same way you wanted to have freedom
dividend
you know we want to have a name it's
catchy final five voting catchy
healthy competition like final four you
know so we want to have
people saying final five voting equals
healthy competition
more choice more voice better results
you know final five voting that's the
system we need so
if we can uh the more and more people
that decide to say that's what they want
it'll make a big difference there's a
lot of energy around ranked choice
voting right now which there should be
um and i think there's a lot of energy
around open primaries too because people
um like dislike their current lack of uh
input um and choice so to me
uh final five voting kind of
incorporates two things that people
already seem very excited about um so
you know like so just
look painting a picture where it's like
if you're right choice voting
you have open primaries and final fives
kind of this uh beautiful
combination and it also stipulates a
number of candidates that is a little
different than what other people
are doing like a lot of the open
primaries they're saying top two or
something like like top three and i've
been convinced
uh that five is a good way to go because
you'd like to have some more options
especially of a ranked choice voting
format and because as we said we don't
need just
three candidates who could really any
one of them for sure win in a sense you
need also
you know people that have small newer
ideas newer constituencies
one of the toughest things during this
pandemic
is feeling good about yourself
physically a lot of it has to do with
what you're putting in your body we're
all about trying to promote people's
healthy diets here at yang speaks and
one thing that's done the trick
for me and a lot of other people is
athletic
greens i love it because you can just
do it every day it's super easy it's
super convenient just mix it together
add water you drink it and you feel like
you've just had
a whole lot of nutrients and minerals
that your body
has been missing because they're not in
cheetos or whatever the heck you're
eating
so if that sounds like something that
would benefit you definitely check it
out
they've invested a ton of energy and
resources
into figuring out how to support your
immune system
keep you healthy give you nutrients in a
way that your body really likes it
in covid right now i'm doing everything
i can just to stay positive and happy
and one of the ways i do that is through
food
yet if i eat like cheese or grease or
stuff like that i
it never it's not necessarily a good
thing now that i'm 32 my body's falling
apart
so i love athletic greens because it
actually helps
my gut it actually helps me digest so i
just re-up my stash of this stuff i love
it
you put it's like a quick packet or a
scoop you throw it in some water mix it
up
tastes fine or really good depending if
you like this stuff which i do
um and you can i feel better when i eat
frankly like crap because i got my
nutrition
i got my multivitamins and i got my like
immune system balanced um
from athletic greens so i'm a big fan of
this product so if you want to invest in
your health and your gut health today go
to athleticgreens.com
yang you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d
for free that's like liquid sunshine
with your first purchase again that's
athleticgreens.com
yang to get some green in your life you
know you need some green and you're
looking around your kitchen being like
there's nothing green in here
reforming primaries ranked choice voting
that would be a game changer in terms of
the level of
innovation ideas and dynamism and true
democracy
that would exist and then you had this
whole second pillar which is trying to
improve the legislative process
itself uh and i i'd love to hear
especially after you listen to you know
my conversation with justin amash like
what can we do to improve the
legislative process because it does not
seem to be
functioning at a high level legislative
machinery
is not a term i made up i discovered it
in a 1940s publication
and this academic wrote about
legislative machinery as being the
norms rules and practices that
govern how legit the legislative process
is run and and then i of course adopted
that yes because it
spits out the behavior and the results
just as reliably as any machine in my
factory as i said before
so i want to just give an example uh
let's see okay here pocket constitution
it's small i mean it fits in a pocket
right
sorry for this thing let's see if we can
do this for your voters
okay if i want to print the house rules
book here today in my office
i'll put these three reams of paper in
my printer
and press print and then the house rules
will come out
and if i want to when i'm done printing
that
print the senate rules i'll put these
three reams of paper in my printer
i'm sure every member of congress uh has
memorized uh their their respective
rules
uh i'm sure they poured through it uh
you know
painstakingly uh before they were sworn
in
when when we talk about that i mean who
would run anything
functional i mean if you want to talk
about bureaucracy or over regulation
or whatever who would run anything
functional the point about that is
mostly to say
everything we need to change you guys
is not really the stuff that's in the
constitution the constitution
gives states the power to make the rules
of the election
the constitution gives congress the
power to make its own rules
and that's when congress made these six
reams of paper
um so let's change the rules of
elections so we can tell congress to
change these rules of how they do
you know this business that's our
business that we've hired them to do
um and but if i go to again what justin
amash was saying
the fact is there's a lot of rules
clearly um in quantity in the house and
senate
but they're some of the most powerful
rules and
practices and the norms are not even the
ones that are written down
and for example where we are right now
is a period
in history where the power
of the majority leader in the senate and
the speaker in the house
is virtually absolute and we're all
concerned about the power of the
presidency some people want to have more
have less or whatever
but it's shocking how little visibility
there is into the power
of the leaders of the two chambers
who can all by themselves
whenever they want say i'm not going to
allow a vote on that
and i actually always uh when i'm
speaking i often give
you know a hastert rule example so denny
haster was
from illinois a house speaker a long
time ago and he sort of
this rule is this norm is named after
him which is
hastert started saying you know i'm not
gonna let us vote on anything
unless a majority of the majority party
wants that bill to pass which is to say
you know majority of the speaker's party
and
so that's now i you know i've always
said that's how all
speakers run this practice but actually
just yesterday i talked with a former
member of congress
and he corrected me and he said oh the
hastert
he didn't say quite this way but
essentially yeah the hastert rule
old news now the new rule
which you can call you know either the
ryan or pelosi rule is
let's not bring anything to the floor
unless we can pass it with our party
alone
yeah that's a banana standard and but
and that and that's what justin
articulated and i was like that is
bananas uh because like
at that point you're foreclosing the
vast majority of bills and proposals
uh and you just need in this case like
the vast majority of your members to be
on board with something to even raise it
and so then everyone would chill out a
lot of the time be like well we have
nothing to vote on because
you know and and then if you can propose
it
then there's no reason for anyone to
even opine on it because it's like you
can pass this
with your own party and so justin was
saying it's like well if i'm on the
minority party like i really can't do
anything i don't matter it's like
you know half the time you're going to
present the legislation to me i don't
even have time to read it not just if
you're in the minority party you can't
really do anything
virtually everybody other than
leadership can't do anything
because leadership decides which bill
they're going to get forward and it
doesn't
and then they say you know sort of to
their caucus you can choose
this or you can choose exactly this you
know you can have a or you can have a
i mean they don't even really work with
junior members in their own
party we need to publicize this rule and
give it a name
um so that people can be you know
cognizant of it when we're talking to
republicans we should call it the
pelosi ryan rule and when we're talking
to democrats we should call it the ryan
pelosi rule
and you know meaning we should because
everybody thinks if well so
paul ryan adopted it first and then
nancy pelosi
uh maintained it so no actually i think
pelosi
started really running it that way uh
before
when she was speaker before ryan um so
then it is unclear
who you name it after maybe something
that actually gives it like the
technical term
it's like uh the guaranteed passage rule
is that we're not going to vote on
anything unless uh we we can pass it
just with our party
um or the majority passage rule anyway i
think we should call frank
luntz you know the poster he helps
figure out what
language the names are sure yeah let's
ask frank
let's ask frank but but there there
definitely needs to be
like more awareness around this rule
because when justin told me about it i
was like that is
awful uh it would it would be so
disenfranchised for as you're suggesting
the vast majority of legislators because
you know it's like if it gets brought
then
you're just there to rubber stamp it um
and if
if you are a differing opinion then
you're going to end up voting no because
you're like well i i didn't have time to
review this and like it's just getting
sprung on me
and it turns out that uh you can pass it
without me
i know that because you're raising it so
of course i'm going to vote no and so
you end up
destroying whatever vestiges of
bipartisanship might be left
exactly and you know that's why
sometimes people say
you know catherine uh these are good
ideas these changes you want to make but
politicians aren't going to make these
changes because they like how it works
and i say well actually
for example with congress which is what
we're focused on changing the rules for
leadership likes how the rules work but
actually if you want to talk about job
satisfaction
virtually everybody else all the other
hundreds of people
would have better jobs if they went to
washington dc with more
freedom if their bosses were
their district instead of a small number
of behind the scenes i mean
i agreed with you catherine but you you
heard justin's characterization that
scared the heck out of me when he was
like it's actually easier just to keep
your head down and go with the flow
which which is painful um i i like to
believe that there are more folks that
are on the
page you're describing which is they'd
rather go in and be able to exercise
their own judgment and leadership
i did think that was something i didn't
agree with justin on now
you know to be humble about it he works
there and i don't
so he again sort of to expand on that
he's saying
that people like not being in charge
because they're not accountable for
anything and they just
say yes or no according to what
leadership tells them and i say
first of all i don't i don't agree i
think more people that i talk to really
do want to make things happen and go
into public service
for many of the right reasons and then
you know that's sort of their only
they can choose lockstep allegiance to
their party or they can choose
not being there so they just choose
lockstep but i think they'd like to
choose something else
and here's the point if they don't want
to choose something else
once we have the new election rules
there'll be new competition
that comes in that wants the job
under the better legislative machinery
and the better election
rules because it'll be a good job to
have and you can make a difference
people don't
a lot of people don't want a job where
they can't do what needs doing and where
they have to say things they don't
believe and where they have to
promise things they know they're never
going to get done
yeah it would be certainly um
incredibly demoralizing for me let's say
if i showed up and was like hey it turns
out i i
you know i'm talking a big game when i'm
around my constituents
to the press but in reality i'm just
gonna rubber stamp stuff i mean like
like that i
i would not be able to deal with that um
i hope you're right
catherine i hope we have the opportunity
to see how how right you are
well and again if i'm wrong there'll be
new people who do want to do
the thing that needs doing um but
if i'm wrong about the existing people
but people
really do want the system to work and
let me say too there there is not enough
media attention being paid to some of
these mechanics we're talking about too
like the fact that i had to find out
from justin amash
you know or you had to fight out from
your person this is what's fascinating
the fact that you had to find out from
justin amash
after you've just been really competing
at the highest level competition the
land of politics
and yet what wasn't apparent to you is
also not apparent to other not maybe
everybody but to others in that
field about what's really constraining
the system in washington dc so as long
as
we don't understand we can't fix
i talk about this as kind of the emperor
has no
close time which is we have to
you know finally look around and get
that the emperor has no clothes
but we have to really understand where
that came from and um
and you know i'll say something else um
relative to the motivations of people
who serve
the forward in uh in michael's in my
book was
written by by a couple members of
congress who were bipartisan yeah so
that they they wanted to be better what
i love about it is they're both
veterans so mike gallagher the
republican in the marines and chrissy
the democrat chrissy houlihan
uh from pennsylvania mike gallagher from
wisconsin and uh
so we have marines in air force and they
essentially say in there in the forward
is you know we served our country in the
military
we love it we're trying to serve but
this is making it impossible for us to
do so and like why are we like supposed
to throw rocks at each other
we kind of like each other we on the
same
team the same for america team when
we're in the military
and we show up here for the same reasons
and we're like not even allowed to eat
with each other or talk to each other
yeah the whole thing it seems like a
bizarro
high school it's like a high school of
adult millionaires where you show up and
it's like you should go sit over there
um yeah i'm sorry and no but they said
they want to make it different and so
those are the people
and and there's justin amash telling the
truth he wants to make it different
and i have here's an art here's a op-ed
i don't know if we can see it but
in milwaukee journal sent sentinel from
a state senator uh dale kuenga a
republican in wisconsin
and a state representative daniel riemer
a democrat
from wisconsin and they wrote an op-ed
jointly in may of this year in wisconsin
when the national
view of wisconsin was division division
division
and they wrote this op-ed where they
came out in support of
final five voting because they are the
co-sponsors of the final five voting
bill in wisconsin
and they said in there everybody thinks
we're divided and yet look at all the
things we agree on
and look at all the motivations that we
have you know to change people's lives
and so they said
also they said we take seriously now
that they understand
uh you know as so many people haven't
paid attention to that
each state legislator is in charge of
these election rules for congress
so they're saying we can't just blame
congress
because we're in the legislature and we
made these
well people before us made these
dysfunctional rules of elections party
primaries
plurality voting so now we
need to be involved in changing it and i
see these people all the time
i just think we need to provide space
and support
for the people who are the existing
elected
politicians who are coming out to say it
needs to be different
okay i know how it is you've been
listening to a lot of stuff lately
including this podcast thank you
and you have wired your buds and you're
like
maybe i should spring for wireless
earbuds but you're afraid you're going
to lose them
you're afraid they're too expensive now
if that describes you
you should definitely check out the new
wireless earbuds from raycon
i gotta say the newest model the
everyday e25 earbuds
their best ones yet six hours of play
time
more bass more compact design you can
listen to your own music and no one else
can hear it they can't even tell you
have earbuds in
they stay in your ears and are
comfortable
uh they look great but they're invisible
so them looking great is actually not
that big a deal
if this sounds like something you want
to check out and you can feel smart
about it because
it's really the same value for a lot
less money
all right honestly i like these things
because i like bumping the bass
particularly on the subway
or just riding i ride the i ride a
scooter around new york city so i like
bumping the base i don't have to listen
to people or
frankly talk to people particularly in
covid so i think raycon's earbuds have
really really strong
audio quality which i love celebrities
think they're cool too uh so whether
it's snoop dogg
or even j.r smith who just won a title
and is not wearing a shirt
ever um right now these guys use them
they endorse the product the people who
like music or like with stylish
are big fans of this so for a limited
time get
percent off your order at buy raycon dot
com slash yang that's buy raycon
dot com slash yang for a special 15
discount on raycon
wireless earbuds make sure to check it
out now while this deal is running by
raycon.com
yang
so what are you seeing uh like what does
the movement look like right now and
what gives you the most optimism
or concern
what gives me the most optimism
is seeing people like dale and danny in
wisconsin from different parties right
that op-ed
seeing uh chrissy and mike write that
op-ed scene
in wisconsin our leadership group
of business and community leaders
includes
democrats and republicans so for example
our first big meeting when we were
moving for this in wisconsin
we had 400 people in a ballroom
and two of our founding
you know leaders stood up one is you
know a tall
younger entrepreneurial republican and
another is
a petite progressive
funder in wisconsin and they sort of
stood up and said
um andy said you know
i held a fundraiser for trump in my home
in the 2016 election
and line said and i am you know a very
large progressive fundraiser and then
they said
we don't agree on much
but guess what we agree on this that the
system is broken
that the rules of the game are the
reason the system's not working for
anyone and we're going to stay united
on what these rules should be
even while we will continue to have
different policy views we're going to
donate to different candidates
we're going to vote different ways but
we're going to believe
in rules that incent whoever ends up
getting elected to work together to make
this happen
so here's where the where's the reform
movement is and let me correct myself
i actually never unless i make a mistake
talk about being in political reform
i'm in political innovation and that's
what i invite people to join is this
movement for political innovation
innovation is breakthrough
changing these rights
is too often been a trojan
horse for partisan advantage
so sometimes in our existing duopoly you
know democrats would be for a reform
that might really help democrats win but
not change the likelihood we get results
or republicans might be for a reform
that will make it more likely
republicans win
but won't change behavior of winners
innovation
focuses on changing the results not
necessarily changing the winners
and uh an innovation is breakthrough and
so that's what we're doing
now in this political innovation
movement and specifically final
five voting which we have to change
first we can't change these crazy you
know rules and everything until you have
people who have
different electoral incentives so we
start with the elections
this constitution article one gives all
the power
to the legislators it will to each state
to make the rules of the game for
elections
so each state can implement final five
voting on its own
in half the states they don't even need
any politician to agree with them
although i suggest many politicians
ballot initiatives love ballot
initiatives
you just get a bunch of people together
yes although i'm gonna
i'm gonna give a word of caution on
ballot editions at the moment the second
thing is
uh in any state you can have legislation
and so for example in wisconsin we don't
have ballot initiatives we need to do it
through legislation
and we have um you know dale and danny
who i just mentioned
dale karinga danny riemer co-sponsoring
this bill
we have other republican democrats
co-sponsors already
and when uh we eventually pass it and
the governor signs it then our
federal delegation will be elected under
these rules of the game and mike
gallagher who wrote the forward
is saying to the people in wisconsin yes
i'd like to be in a congress where
people come
under these rules of the game which is
amazing wisconsin look at that yeah
yeah wisconsin i mean we were a leader
in the last in the progressive era of
reform political reform so
i expect wisconsin is going to be a
leader again now
so here's the thing in a legislative
state
we started in 2017. these are not quick
fixes we need to get buy-in
and we're doing that bit by bit and we
have a plan
you know where it will take anywhere
from two to six years in a legislative
state
to get buy-in from everybody to and
everybody
from many people grass tops grassroots
grass middles opinion
leaders elected officials formers
currents etc
republicans democrats independents broad
buy-in
and then make the change here's my
caution on ballot initiatives
you can win a ballot initiative for any
of these changes through brute force
okay so you can get enough money to
get the message out and it's a good
message i mean i think it should win
but you can get enough money to get the
message out
and make whoever you need to be the
villain to be the villain to pass it at
51 percent
but then you've changed key parts of
your democracy
without really major buy-in
necessarily i would really love to see
even the ballot initiative states take
far more time in advance
getting the buy-in across the spectrum
instead of figuring out what coalitions
they need to
cobble together to get themselves a 50
plus one vote which kind of usually
leaves 49
of the people not liking it so right
when we're trying to get innovation
that will allow us to have policies that
we can broadly agree on
and sort of move forward together we're
moving there
by passing it in a bit of the same kind
of brute force
way again look i'll take innovation how
it comes
and i totally support the ballot
initiative in alaska right now
alaska is going to vote on final four
voting you mentioned it in your op-ed
with bill weld yep they're voting on
november 3rd i call it the other swing
state
do we swing towards a functional
democracy or not so let's watch alaska
and as you noted also massachusetts is
going to vote on ranked choice voting
i'm totally happy about those
but i also don't want to see every
ballot initiative fought in court
after it passes you go look at some
ballot initiatives at kent theory a
business person
uh ran in colorado and he started by
getting a lot of support
from from lots of people across
across ideology to sort of agree on the
ballot language so then when the people
passed it there was not
sort of a manufactured opposition
because there was
you know work done ahead of time and i
just think that's respectful
for the democracy i mean i i love
getting buy-in
catherine at the same time uh we're
short on uh
time time's not a luxury we have you
know what i mean it's like like we we've
been laboring with this
dysfunctional uh legislature for a long
time
and anything that's gonna speed up
innovation and efficacy i am for
so i'm just going to throw that out
there being like look i love getting
buy-in too but
i mean right now people are hurting and
looking up and being like why does it
seem like no one's listening to us
and i think this would help our
legislators actually listen to the
people again um so i'm a huge fan
of i mean obviously you're championing
this stuff like i i just i'm just not
that worried about like the
you know like the uh the the
the preparation of the carpet so to
speak i mean you know
we just woke up and 51 percent of people
in the state were voting for it i would
just be thrilled
well and i would be thrilled to again
i'll take it how it comes having said
that
we're not really going to have ballot
initiatives until
uh the next election cycle which is not
two thousand you mean twenty two
thousand twenty-two
so how about if you guys people who
wanna run a ballot initiative
in 2022 start going now
and i agree with that a whole i agree
with that wholeheartedly
uh and i think i think that's why this
conversation is so
uh awesome and timely uh i'm um
incredibly grateful to you for uh
championing
these ideas that i think are tremendous
your book uh with michael was great um i
have my copy over there in the bed i'm
not gonna run over
the the but you have a copy behind you i
can see it and you had the cup
um the politics industry i have two
great books behind me i have
uh this book called the war on norway oh
thank you
that's very kind of you catherine okay
so everybody by anders book of course
but um and then yes this is our book
michael's mine the politics industry how
political innovation can break partisan
gridlock and save our democracy
here's the thing i want you guys to all
buy this book
but because i want the change all the
authors proceeds from this book
go directly into the institute for
political innovation to work
for the changes so i won't buy new shoes
with this
um and that which which is what i'd like
to say another great reason to buy the
book one it's a good book and two
your your money is going to go to
political innovation
which we desperately need the the
organization this
these funds go into that you mentioned i
founded in the introduction it's called
the institute for political innovation
it's political dash innovation.org
this institute one of our main
objectives
is to help connect ideas
to actual campaigns to make the changes
legislative campaigns or ballot
initiative campaigns for final five like
we just talked about
so if people who are watching want to
know if there's a campaign in their
state so they can get involved
get to us at political dash
innovation.org you know go there
and you can get in touch with us or if
you want to start a campaign
or if you want to be an enormous
political philanthropist
and donate or a small political
philanthropist and donate
come there and we can make turn
the idea into the campaign so any of you
who worked
on anders campaign
may want to now work on a campaign
to change the rules of the game to
essentially make
the world safe for democracy to make the
world safer you know innovation etc
and uh and make the world safe for
results i would say
and that's that's what we'd love to
partner with you guys on
make the world safe for results i love
it uh
and there are many folks in the yang
gang who are going to take you up on
this
political innovation dot org
uh i am a huge fan of
uh of anything that's going to make the
people's votes matter more which this
100
will uh no you're a champion for
lowercase d
democracy grateful to you for it and
you're just getting started we have a
lot of work to do but i i encourage
everyone to buy the book it's a great
book
uh it makes a very compelling case for
the fact that
we're not going to see the results we
want unless the incentives within the
politics industry and the political
system change
and these mechanisms will change them in
a very real way and make our votes
matter
uh so you and i will be in this for a
while catherine like
you should know like this was not like
hey let's have you on a podcast and like
because we have to grind on these things
we know that
these totes have changed um sort of so
changes don't
come quickly or easily but hey you know
like we're going to be here a while
i feel i feel similarly to you you know
when you're trying to get a new and
innovative idea
that's how i think those of us that are
now in final five voting were like has
anybody heard of final five voting do
you like it can we sell it to more
people you know
i like final five voting that's that's
fantastic and and people do i mean it's
definitely happening
but we just definitely need more and we
need them faster to your point
uh we're the the clock is ticking
on our democracy yes the clock is
ticking
and on our unity
i would say yep on our ability to come
together and solve these problems
and our politics isn't helping our media
is not helping social media is not
helping
um but the mechanics of our elections
are also not helping
uh and i'm a big process person it's
like if you
uh if you want a certain result uh then
oftentimes like the most important thing
is what does the process look like and
is a process designed to deliver you
results
and right now right now we can very
clearly see uh
we've not been getting results for quite
some time um
and again you and michael make a very
convincing case that we shouldn't expect
different results unless we have a
different process
thank you thanks for having me today
it's
a true true pleasure to talk to you
and all of the people that have been
interested in your work and
really mobilized and engaged
in this system because in the end that
is what democracy returns to yeah
i'm very very i i'm very very interested
in your work
uh and all the folks too the folks you
guys describe who look up and say like
why
don't we have a more dynamic system why
aren't more points of view represented
why does it seem like
this duopoly uh it has um
no uh permanent ongoing perpetual
uh control over everything you know like
the
the mechanisms you're describing um
would help change it
um and for all the folks who've been
looking around for a set of solutions
look no further than uh than what you
all are building
um so consider me a friend and champion
um uh because i'm a
i am like you know we need we need to
restore our democracy in a
literal sense thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you